[Music]
so my name's Ben Fulton and I work with
the research technologies division at
Indiana University and research
technologies is the group inside of
University information technology
services that supports people with
large-scale computing problems that they
need to solve so we are not supporting
the printers we're not supporting the
email servers or the Wi-Fi or any of the
typical business of the university we
support strictly the people who do
computing and all of our supercomputers
are clustered nodes so they're available
as shared servers and what it's sort of
similar to asking for a set of nodes in
Amazon say if you ask for 10 nodes on
Amazon you get 10 virtual machines if
you ask for 10 nodes on one of our
supercomputers you get actual physical
nodes in 2013 we introduced a big red 2
which was a Cray machine it has 344
nodes that are strictly cpu-based it's
got their dual socket 16 cores so you
have 32 cores to work with also 676 16
core nodes that also have Nvidia K 20
GPUs on them if you ask for those you'll
probably if you ask for say 10 nodes in
that list you'll get 210 machines that
are actually sitting inside that cabinet
you can see there on the screen and the
10 nodes will be sitting very close to
each other so that the communications
between them if you need to high-speed
communications between your nodes would
be very fast because they're all sitting
right next to each other so we are
pretty excited about providing these 10
these thousand nodes and the 600 nodes
with NVIDIA K 20s on him but you know
there was no at in 2013 there was no PI
torch there was no tensorflow so we
couldn't actually provide things like
that but we did provide well I shouldn't
say we provide
but things like CUDA open ACC you had to
basically write your own code to work
with these GPUs and I will say that
we've learned that the useful life of a
supercomputer is probably about five
years so I'll come back to that a little
bit I want to talk now about data
storage we provide the we like to
provide or we would like to provide as
policy of ubiquitous computing at IU and
what I mean by that is we'd really like
it is if you had all the supercomputing
power that you wanted all the computing
power that you wanted if you wanted a
lot of disk space we'd like to give you
all your disk space if you want a lot of
CPU hours we'd like to give you a lot of
CPU hours and so we're providing this
scholarly data archive which is
available pretty much to anybody at the
University and the SDA is seventy five
petabytes of storage it's long term tape
data storage so we're keeping it we plan
on keeping it forever ask me again in a
hundred years if we succeeded we make
two copies of all the data that's in the
in the entire system one copies in
Bloomington the other copy is up here in
Indy and that's in case of the you know
tornado or earthquake or something that
might destroy one of the copies it is
best to be used with larger files so you
don't really want to toss a thousand one
hundred byte files into the SDA because
it doesn't it'll take forever to recover
all of those from the tapes if you ever
come down to Bloomington and come to our
data center you can watch the robots and
pushing the the tape drives around that
we do offer tours of our data center so
the robots are a lot of fun to watch
it's a IBM TS 3500 system so for
short-term data storage we have the the
debt what we call the data capacitor
it's got five petabytes of storage and a
fast InfiniBand connection so it
connects quickly to big red to and the
other computers sort of what our goal
was in the data capacitor was that you
would take your data would probably
which would be living in the SD a you
would copy it over to the DC you'd run
your computer computations on it and
then sort of discharge
the capacitor by deleting the data
excuse me
so that's what sort of the idea the
ideal way to use the system was and so
because of that we don't anticipate that
you'll need backups so we don't back out
the DC we don't have any quotas so you
know if you have thousands and thousands
of files that you need to push onto the
DC to to use your computing to do your
computing then it's there but it will be
automatically deleted after 60 days so
that's sort of a surprising way that the
the DC works it's not something that
people are very used to since 2013 we've
added some other computing options karst
there's a lenovo system it's got about
300 nodes on it they're all CPUs there
are no GPUs involved each compute node
has 32 gigabytes of RAM 250 gigabytes of
local storage so what you can do if you
prefer is copy your files to the local
storage directly rather than copying to
the DC and that'll be faster it is a
spinning disk and there are some nodes
on the cars that are 64 gigs of ram
which is better and they have 24
terabytes again that's a spinning disk
storage we later on added another system
called carbonate which has 72 more nodes
and what we were kind of looking for out
of carbonate was space for people who
didn't think that 64 gigabytes of memory
was enough so these nodes all have 256
gigs of memory
many of them have 512 gigs so if you
request from the large memory storage
you'll get the 512 gating machines and
each one each carbonate system has four
five hundred and gigabyte SSDs so
that'll be extremely fast and it's all
mounted together on the attempt so you
don't have to think about you know is it
on disk one or is it on disk two where
is it and I couldn't find a picture of
the carbonate cabinet so I put a picture
of Marengo cave up here we named all of
our machines after different kinds of
rocks if you have a chance to go down to
two Marengo and see the rock formations
you should that is a
where we were basically the beginning of
this year at the beginning of 2019 in
next year in 2020 it's the Indiana
University Bicentennial and you may be
aware our President Michael McRobbie
actually has a PhD in computer science
so he is very interested in keeping us
state-of-the-art in computing systems
he's he was chief information officer of
the University and then he was named
president so we try in order to keep him
involved we try to keep our systems
pretty well updated so research desktop
you know personal computing the Greger
mentioned that he likes command lines
and I like command lines too and in 1981
that's all we had was command lines
today we have beautiful point-and-click
Mouse GUI interfaces and lovely things
like that if you're you doing
supercomputing in 1981 you use the
command line prompt today still using
the command line prompt but we're going
we're trying to change that and the
reason we're trying to change that is
because we have a lot of students and a
lot of people coming down who don't
really want to use the command line
prompt so we're providing several nodes
on this research desktop system which is
basically a point-and-click Windows GUI
system the nodes that we have on this
aren't as fast or as powerful as the
compute nodes and you have to share them
so several people are going to be
logging into one research desktop note
at a time but it does allow you to run
the programs that a lot of people are
used to our studio Jupiter got a lot of
Jupiter today MATLAB Stata and there's
based on a couple years ago we piloted a
system very similar to this called cars
desktop and that was hugely popular
everybody loved it so we kind of took it
to another level here on research
desktop and it's based on a thin link
which is a desktop service system it's a
VNC and it's base built by a company in
Sweden called scindia
no I was telling you about the data
capacitor where you put an unlimited
number of files basically and eventually
they'd be automatically deleted well
people really liked being able to put
unlimited files on the system they
didn't like it so much when we deleted
them so even though we wanted to set it
up that way as part of the ubiquitous
computing strategy we are now moving
away from that with our new system
called slate and slate is a 10 petabytes
spinning disk system yeah it does fast
64 gigabytes second throughput but it is
not subject to a purge policy you can
take your once you get a slate account
you can put your files there and they
will stay there as long as a slate as an
existence probably five years ago and
there is a quota 800 gigs for personal
files if you sign up for a project
you're as if you need space for your
project your research project that
you're doing you get 15 terabytes of
stereo space and if you need more you
will provide more for money somewhere
around about 2017 tensorflow started to
get popular and we started getting
requests to have it put on big red -
especially the GPU version so we could
take advantage of all these GPU versions
the first few versions of tins are flow
we're fine we install them and it all
worked and then eventually they upgraded
it and when we installed it on br-2 we
started getting a library library
problems why have your errors and we
couldn't even get it to work and for
most software we can take the source
code and recompile it against the Krait
libraries that are on br-2 but we never
actually got that working with
tensorflow
I can't really explain why I was I went
and in there and tried to get it to work
but it didn't work and we went to talk
to Crais and Crais said oh your
libraries are out of date and he said
well great can we get new libraries and
we said well we know your system is so
old that we don't really support the
libraries anymore so what we did is we
went to carbonate we added some several
nodes to carbonate 12 nodes they are
dual 12 cores
192 gigs per node there's 2 terabytes of
SSD on each one
eight of the nodes have P 100's GPUs
which is a powerful GPU for deep
learning processing and for the notes
have dual V 100 Suite 1 each node has 2
GBS you can work with the V 100 some a
little bit more powerful than the P 100
sauce I talked about that so here's the
specs on the Pascal the Tesla the P 100
for a double precision operations you
can pull down 4.7 teraflops in the
particular configuration that we have on
carbonate in C you doing single
provision 9.3 and 1/2 precision 18.7
teraflops the interconnect is 32 Gibbs
second because the cards that we are
using are PCI based and NVIDIA provides
a faster interface that we don't
actually provide called an NV link which
isn't probably provide about ten times
the speed of the interconnect and we're
discovering as we try to push the system
to his boundaries that the speed of
processing is not the problem the
problem is the speed of the interconnect
the tesla machines slightly faster
double precision of seven teraflops
single precision fourteen teraflops and
what Nvidia tells us is that for deep
learning applications you can get as
much as 112 teraflops I don't fully
understand that but I'm happy to accept
it and it's the same PCI interconnect
that provides us with 32 gigabyte per
second we provide a lot of software
pretty much if somebody is interested in
a piece of software we provide it for
you or if it's not if it's fairly
obscure we'll only tell you to install
it yourself have you can do that we'll
try to support you and do that but we do
have lots and lots of deep learning
software psyche it we've talked about
tens or flow PI torch CNT K scikit-learn
you can use R if you're using research
desktop you can use our studio and let's
got a ton of algorithms and the various
packages that are available h2o h2o Weka
or if you need to do your own
programming on the on the GPUs you have
the CUDA and open ACC
so that's that and now this is the
machine that we are about to introduce
hopefully next year to celebrate the
Bicentennial it's called big red 200 so
we've gone from big red to big red to
and then a couple of other machines in
there and then we went to big red 200
big red 200 is going to be a crash a
stew system and that is craze the newest
most modern system and we're it's going
to be very interesting to see how we can
get it all put together the only one I'm
aware of that's also or nearly in
production is the one at nurse a
national energy research scientific
computing Center they're putting
together a craze Shasta system called
Perlmutter and that should be online
probably I don't think it's online yet
but it should be online very soon
probably ahead of us and now at this
point I'm spitting out words that I
don't fully understand because the
Shasta system is fully it's not
something I know really how it works
it's the crazy shot interconnect I'm
sure that's very fast the Cray Eureka AI
suite for Shasta I'm sure that's very
cool and what is for what the kind of
the goal of bigger at 200 is to help us
with our Grand Challenges that we're
doing as a part of our Bicentennial we
have a grand challenge on precision
health where we want to solve at least
one type of cancer we have a grand
challenge I'm preparing for
environmental change and one on
responding for the addictions crisis and
all these projects will have space on
the big red 200 and space and time on
big red 200 to do the calculations that
they need to solve their problems
this slide is sort of the slide that we
are using to advertise what bigger red
200 does and there's a comparison there
between big red 200 big big red big red
- I'm big red 200 so big red is actually
a 20 teraflop machine so that and we
were tired out quite a long time ago and
big red 2 was pedal flops
and the new big red 200 now is almost up
to six petaflop
six million times faster than your
iPhone xs and the memory on it is enough
to process seventy one thousand gigabyte
long brain scans simultaneously and ram
how many credit hours would i have to
get to get student access that way if
you were an undergraduate you would have
to I think that you'd have to be
enrolled in the university and do six or
twelve or some amount of student hours
we do provide alternatives to that if
you could if you're working on I'll bet
that's your question right no no okay if
we do provide affiliate account so if
you're actually doing research and you
want to work with one of our researchers
you just get a hold of someone saying
Gregor perhaps and tell them that you
have this really cool project you can
sponsor you for an affiliate account and
that's how you would get an access for
that what so the Shasta is a
supercomputer with them it has an
d---rom CPUs the Nvidia's are gonna be
all v1 hundreds they haven't announced
the specific configuration of the GPUs
yet and it'll have the the Cray in her
neck that I mentioned earlier and wow I
was not expecting to be done that fast I
was probably talking very much too
quickly I'm sorry about that but that's
pretty much the extent of what I have
are there any more questions
who gets the name of supercomputers
what's that who gets the name the
supercomputers I imagine Michael
McRobbie does or it's probably there's
committee someplace that
Oh on the quarries
I mentioned karst and carbonate and
slate I think in the talk though we've
retired a couple of computers we've
retired Mason and we've retired quarry
so an actual computer named quarry so
those are some of the other names that
we hitches I'll go ahead and get the
microphone how does this compare to you
know AWS in terms of cost and
performance like if I wanted to go to a
public cloud I mean why would I go there
instead of if I was a research well for
what we benefit from economies of scale
so the fact that we have even big red to
has its thousand nodes on there if you
wanted to ask for a thousand nodes from
Amazon Web Services or wherever you
would pay a lot more than we are
actually paying for our supercomputer
per CPU hour so we definitely are
benefiting there the downside of using
these computers is that we only have you
know we have the physical Hardware all
of our all of the servers run Red Hat
seven now and if you don't if you want
to run something that's not on Red Hat
seven if you want to run something
that's a GUI and that's something that
you can pick put together easily on
Amazon it's not something we can put
together very easily for you on this
machines you can still use containers
not docker because docker is a doesn't
work well with multi-user systems but
similar containers like singularity so
you could do that but from just from an
ease of use perspective Amazon is better
the computers are our computers are
bigger and faster but not as easy to use
so there is another aspect to this so
this is actually a historical reason why
we have these systems so I had my first
standing next to my office in 1984 so
there was a long time ago but the reason
why we do have these systems is for
Grand Challenge problems and science and
it's a different issue
to do a astrophysics problem whereas us
to do a webservice hosting if you look
at how Amazon and these systems actually
are started out it was offering a couple
of machines to millions or thousands of
users but we have in academia sometimes
the opposite problem we have one user
that requires thought wasn't machines
that's the reason why you saw me talking
about how do I start up actually
thousand virtual machines in order to
for example of Allah wait can we
actually move such loads that he
projects uncoerced into for example
Amazon and as you see is this is also we
now see in Amazon and in an azure that
for specialized high-performance
computing tasks both of these clouds
actually offer specialized resources as
a service so they are competing at one
point with the academic supercomputing
centers but these guys are more flexible
because they may actually have to
reversing a particular astrophysics
quote and have to put have to put down a
particular version of the library and
then share it with the community which
typically is not done in a head of his
way
so you talked a little bit about some
end-of-life issues with big red - and
library support and whatnot in light of
that I'm sort of surprised to hear that
the university is going to custom
hardware again to another Cray
supercomputer can you describe talk to a
little bit about the policy how those
decisions are made why you would do that
versus sort of just a crapload of
commodity hardware well as I say you
know I think we are getting economies of
scale from using these large computers
beyond that there are definite
advantages to the fact that I can put
out this slide up here to come up and
say look at our great new supercomputer
that has serious benefits we can go to
funding agencies we can go to the
National Science Foundation and say hey
look at our cool new supercomputer we're
going to do some really amazing research
we can go to new faculty we can invite
new faculty here and say look at this
great new stuff that you could use if
you come to us so there are definitely
advantages to being sort of at the
forefront of this these machines I can
get a comparable number of peda flops
from a Beowulf cluster of sufficient
size so that like I'm there's some
disconnect here that I'm not I'm not
quite getting I don't know that I really
have a good answer you might be right
there they'd be you know here great
noise so I apologize we I did actually
run these things also in production mode
and we have actually some answers to
this I myself naturally it can built the
system which is much cheaper than this
but this is actually a warranty question
miss in the university or within the
five years that you are doing this the
warranty sometimes it's just better than
you sending ten people and then
replacing on ten different servers ten
different hard drives and doing this and
instead you may actually invite the IBM
or the Lenovo crew and simply say well
its annual warranty please come and
replace that so overall that's toughest
and she purred and also the economy of
scale so if you for example compare the
San Diego machine
this for example here the Indiana
machine or the Texas Austin machine
which are working together with Dell
they get an incredible price reduction
while advertising that they are actually
using their particular system you as an
individual user or company will not be
able to get these price points so there
is really a see status is a financial
benefit from there and then also the the
the support of the bo wolf clusters
cannot be done on such a large scale so
we're talking here
how many costs do you guys have right
now cores how many processors do you
have thousand thousands thousands so if
you're talking about a machine that has
thousand or something like this process
processes taking out the time to get
that thing out of the rack do we redo
the network assertion that's expensive
and and and the cost of the hardware is
nothing in contrast the manpower to push
these things together so this is this is
peanuts by the way I might mention to
the in addition to putting together
bigger at 200 we're putting several
million dollars into upgrading our data
center so that'll be a lot of new stuff
that's involved with that and the this
new Cray is going to be super computers
require a lot of cooling and is gonna
have something called warm water cooling
which I'll be curious to know what that
is because I don't quite understand how
you can cool a supercomputer with warm
water but like clean coal probably so so
where does all the deep learning stuff
happen at IU is it
IUP why is it IU Bloomington is it in
the computer science department is it in
informatics where does it exist I would
say it's more in informatics because
well informatics they do the actual
research on how deep learning works and
how it does well now but you know
there's plenty
applications for deep learning so we
have people in the chemistry department
biology is there are people trying to
figure out new ways to create drugs in
the bottom in bioinformatics by
comparing genomes and things like that
so really all over the place but it's
it's informatics that does what oh oh
I'm in Bloomington yeah I'm Gregerson
Bloomington - no research technologies
is a separate division so the School of
Informatics is where you know research
and discussion or whatever of
informatics is we are support we are
part of university information
technology services so we sue which you
know the 1600 people that support every
computer in the university question up
on the board about utilization rate what
is the utilization rate it's very very
high which is why especially we had
problems in the data capacitor one of
the reasons we had to retire it is
because with all these infinite or
unlimited number of files you could put
in it kept filling up and our data
capacitor specialists would buy some
more hard drives add a petabyte of
storage and next week it would be all
filled up so it's very very full and the
machines are very very full - but part
of that is through is because we're
doing this ubiquitous computing process
in a lot of computing centers what
they'll do is they'll say you need to
get an allocation you need a 10
terabytes of data space and you're going
to get a hundred CPU hours of time and
once you used all that you're done we
don't make people do that and so people
may be less than efficient with their
computing hours or space so I'm still
wondering about the price and compared
to public cloud say particularly
specialized hardware like Google TPU and
maybe and or even asking them to sponsor
that has have there any pricing models
been run to actually look at this as
opposed to
we need to make sure to keep our
department that is that information is
not in my knowledge
McGregor might have apologized again
there is actually an active research
activity within the NSF as well as which
in the larger community of this so this
is just one system out of many but we
have the largest supercomputing
agglomeration in the United States is
known under the project name exceed and
that is a 30 million dollar funded NSF
project and as part of this they have
conducted the cost analysis of what's
cheaper to run these clusters or AWS I
don't want to give the wrong information
because there may be different opinions
about what they actually count but if
there's a interest in this we can try to
bring you in contact with together with
those researchers that have done these
studies and I think the one of the more
famous study system and actually
Berkeley labs where they actually did
calculate some prices and they still
came up was that the supercomputers are
cheaper than some are Muslim services
but it really depends on what kind of
applications you're running on it if
you're running a web service you
shouldn't run them on these machines so
you should go out to Amazon have you do
your class assignment of Jupiter
notebooks you shouldn't run them
actually on these things you should run
them under your laptops or you should be
running them on google call up because
you get this to us for free
if you however do an analysis of
chemical compounds or something like
this that does require the fast
interconnect Network for
for InfiniBand for example for a low
latency communication you go on these
systems however in Amazon when you go
with a normal virtual machine or
container they're mostly done with high
latency and this is where the
differences is so you can't immediately
say what's cheaper it really depends on
what what you want to run you know it's
almost the thing is this is you want to
go from New York to Los Angeles what you
do buy a Formula One race car and go to
really fast there or rent a plane ticket
or buy yourself a bicycle these are all
different applications
certainly the bicycle is cheaper but you
take much longer to get there and these
guys here when you're doing an an
academic paper sometimes you have to do
it within one month because otherwise
someone else competes with you so it's
not just a question of the dollar amount
but it is the return of investment can
be not only being measured in dollar but
also in the scientific output and you
can look up my name and and I actually
have a framework that measures a
scientific output for these for all the
systems in the United States was a
statistical framework to do scientific
impact analysis and his boss is doing
return of investment so correct steward
so he has several papers there and
they're being published in exceed 2019
we have an entire workshop hosted on
exactly that question excellent actually
I tried it if you google just cloudmesh
he's like the second result so you can't
miss him all right
what is like the data security that you
can put on this is it Export Control
does it allow government sensitive
classified or is it just all public data
I mean like your research projects can
you do Defense Department of Defense I
don't think there's any reason why you
couldn't I don't know of any projects
that we're doing like that the security
for the computers is fairly
straightforward and simple we're using
we sort of guarantee that if you put
data there nobody else is going to be
able to read it so but of course you
know if you're familiar with Linux
systems you're perfectly welcome to set
your files to be readable by all by
everyone and we don't actually stop you
from setting your files up so I would
say the control is there more have it
have to do with training and paperwork
and stuff we do have plenty of HIPAA
type projects so there are a lot of
people that are doing working with
personal health information you know
questions for Ben no comment the
question is what you do with the old
computers what do you do with the old
computers big red we actually sold to a
smaller University and I can't remember
which one that was what Arkansas big red
- it's not retired yet it'll be retired
very soon and Cray is we're giving that
one back to Cray sort of like you would
trade in your own car for a new car so I
didn't even know Cray was still in
business and I could probably do a whole
nother talk on the history of Cray put
their own right now by Hewlett Packard
so because SGI owned them for a while
[Music]
you